with a movie like this where you get to
travel the world and someone else is
paying for it is it sort of like is the
script pretty good yeah I'm in yeah yeah
yeah it's like oh it's a Kevin Kevin
Hart film let me read it like and then
it's like okay you know it's like afgar
oh yeah great great it's like what we're
shooting all over the world yes I'm in
let's get the deal done yeah yeah it was
it's an easy again the script was there
so that that's always makes it that's
where it starts if it's not on the page
it doesn't play so yeah it starts with a
script but then all these other things
are bonuses you guys as I said you got
to travel the world is what's the place
of the locations you went to that if you
could go back tomorrow you would go
immediately Venice Italy Italy you could
have been us i' definitely visit Cortina
again oh Cortina was nice too Cortina
was gorgeous I had I had gone back after
that oh you did did yeah yeah well to
the dolomites and stuff oh right right
it was just so breathtaking I think the
Italy portion
for sure I mean I'd been to Venice
before and i' actually several times in
my life but um I've never been to uh
that area of Italy where the where
Cortina is gorgeous just so beautiful
again our Hub our main Hub was always
Belfast Ireland which I look back yeah I
look at so fondly at it it was
definitely dark in the winter though
like it's dark and cold yeah yes I I
have experienced uh experienced that um
what do you think it is for all three of
you what do you think it is about the
heist genre and watching bands of
Misfits on screen that just people love
um I think it's the same probably thing
that got you into the the film industry
you want to go on the journey with the
characters they they're painting this
beautiful world you're you feel like
you're a part of the crew you have to
figure out what's actually transpiring
and how to solve the the the puzzle I
think it just you're a part of it you
don't feel separated from it that's my
assumption I'm sorry about you but like
yeah it gets exciting it's like I mean
you have like video game consoles I see
behind you and stuff like that again you
want as do I like I love feeling a part
of the adventure and that's what I that
always gets me involved and to have like
a crew like this it it it makes it and
the the the interplay between it all you
you feel close you feel intimate with
them it's exciting for me I think it's
fun to see how each of the characters
play different roles in the mission and
how they all come together in the end
and as an audience you feel part of it
and you feel like you're succeeding in a
mission with them mhm yeah I mean I
think it's one of those structures of
Storytelling that seems to always work
because you as an audience member you
know it's going to turn out okay but
you're still interested in are they
going to fail or not it's just a
structure that works in storytelling and
film and it's it's especially in film
it's amazing that way it's just one of
those special structures that is going
to be repeated again and again there's
going to be variations on variations on
variations of it and I think it's
entertaining when you guys saw the
shooting schedule what was the day that
you had circled in terms of I cannot
wait to film this or oh my effing God we
have to film this oh I always look
forward for The Ensemble scenes yeah
those were the ones like again like
working with the these people like
that's that was the best part was the
The Ensemble and just being excited to
work with them there was not like a spe
specific day of shooting but it was just
building out the relationships with the
other actors and their characters you
know that always was exciting for me at
least for me as an actor that's but much
more fun in in the scenes when we were
when we were all there when all of us
were there but also like off camera too
like if it was a day where there were
long setups and stuff that's usually the
most if not always the most boring part
of film making where you just have to
wait but we waited with each other most
of the time and that just made the day
much easier and and much faster and much
more pleasant I think I looked forward
to the group scenes yeah we would always
ask like are you on tomorrow tomorrow
okay but also flying around the world on
Netflix's dime so that was also waiting
for those
scenes sorry totally yeah so uh a lot of
people won't realize but I believe Vic
Armstrong was your second unit director
um and you also got to work with f f
Gary gray which are like two really good
people I'm not sure how much you worked
with Vic but can you sort of talk about
maybe how they're similar how they're
different and like what it's like
working with your first unit and your
second unit director I think it all
stems from F at at the end of the day
because it's his vision of the world and
what's it you have to have the captain
of the ship and if it's not aligned like
it doesn't matter the second unit it all
has to come from one point uh eventually
so I think it all interplayed with each
other and I I
understand I think didn't feel a big
difference yeah me either no I think you
know on on some films whether it's
second unit or or first unit you know
it's you're sometimes you just you just
know that you're just leaving it to the
to the director and the DPS of the day
to just do their thing and you you trust
that it's going to be it's going to fit
and suit the genre perfectly you know
and and and then we we could just
concentrate on the acting part of it and
stuff other films sometimes you're like
concerned of like the way they're
shooting it and and and you want to know
about why they're doing it this way or
that way or the other way but on this
film whether we were on first or second
Union it was a strong camera crew and
strong DPS and DP and and strong
directors behind the camera so it was
like all we had to do is like get our
scenes right or make sure our scenes
were written correctly and and acted
correctly and that was a that's that's a
nice it's nice to work on a set like
that yeah I think they both felt very
similar yeah I already got to stop I'm
just going to say congrats I had a lot
of fun watching it last night I know
it's going to be a hit for you guys uh
enjoy the rest of your speed dating than
Ste than you st Glad You Came
Back